ciao a tutti andrea erano secoli che non
metteva un video per colpa dell'estate
per colpa dei ghiacci e per colpa di
tutte quante altre cose però come potete
vedere non vi ho abbandonato e culo
comunque stiamo pensando recentemente a
una cosa sai che io una fissa una fissa
abbastanza stupida di chiedere alle
persone che mi stanno attorno cose
assurde e soprattutto cominciare a
fissarmi sulla cosa come se fosse una
cosa vera è senza dubbio una delle mie
domande preferite e se potessi scegliere
un potere magico quale vorreste poter
essere invisibili potresti eri ragazzi
che si spogliano oppure anche saper
cambiare forma del corpo così aggiungere
un trucchino cui un pochino qui così
potrei fare il boia usa ma tipo
moltiplicano i ragazzi per fare le orge
vale come potere no certo anche per i
quattro ball ok va bene
beh io potere magico cielo che sarebbe
sommergere il futuro grazie a preferire
nelle parte per quello comunque vuoi che
ti lega giovani straniere
la carta della torre delle distruzioni
quella carta del demonio sacra di un
satanasso e le carte
morte allora facciamo venuti di qualcosa
significano così titolati questi ultimi
minuti di vita il pranzo è tranquillo no
no ti prego sa palle anche a me la carta
del coro si vede che ti piace mostrarmi
peccato assurda la carta della bendata
perché ti piace attaccati agli anni di
enti in cui se fosse uno zaino dell'est
e non solo quelle e poi la carta di uno
che lancia per terna sta veramente o un
appeso al contrario quindi la carta di
spider man
purtroppo questo non so cosa vuol dire
lo sapevo che ci sapeva fare questa
ragazza tv uno occhio interno è molto
sensibile alla magia e il ragazzo su
ruota con un anno insomma ti piaccia da
quelli è come se non bastasse molto
problema studi supereroe voglio dire
dopo che i primi supereroi wonder woman
spiderman e superman si sono
accalappiati i poteri più figli tipo
originava servola repice verso le pareti
i supereroi che sono venuti dopo si sono
dovuti prendere gli scarti superpoteri
che gli hanno lasciato batman and
company e si accontentano con quello che
hanno i m infiammante mangiatori di
biciclette aggiornato la posizione di
lord cicala nord una volta invisibile
con occhio dipinte su faccia il suo
potere da cicale e veramente granata
bisogna sicuramente chiedere l'aiuto di
qualcuno che mi dice che l'uomo che
riesce a produrre lacca dalle ascelle
però quello che scassa la coca cola
corpi di paso doble nonno che nei giusti
dell'umano
vi prego quello non ha fatto altro
l'ultima volta che chiedere di provare
gli stivali davvero come l'ha pure chi
li mette signori sulla bara si è
comunque quella che lo speri logicamente
solamente una crema di cocoa al burro di
yogurt con brillantini e io che pensavo
che fosse un bambino innamorato di umana
lo dice perché non vuole che venga
scoperta la sua storia di sesso con
harry potter ciccio sì lo so comunque
che ne dici della donna russa e che
potere ai capelli rosso tenti proprio
come quelli di ariel e inoltre parla
russo
ottima voglio dire a voi non è mai
capitato una cosa del genere non vi
siete mai ne sia fantasticare su questo
tipo di cose e soprattutto se voi avesse
forse prima di scegliere un superpotere
quale sarebbe ti prego fatemelo sapere
scritto un commentino un video e
risposta perché ne ho bisogno